as a growing number of countries around
the world join the US in recognizing
opposition leader Juan Y doe as interim
president and in calling for Nicolas
Maduro to step down the leader of
Venezuela controls what some estimate
are the largest oil reserves in the
world and yet the country is an economic
collapse and that is creating a huge
humanitarian catastrophe an estimated 3
million people have fled Venezuela since
2015 many of them to neighboring
Colombia the political crisis may affect
a generation of children says the former
US ambassador to Japan Caroline Kennedy
she co-wrote new Washington Post op-ed
with the headline as Colombia welcomes
fleeing Venezuelans children bear the
heaviest burden she visited a Colombian
border town just two weeks ago and only
on CBS this morning Caroline Kennedy
joins us here in studio 57 ambassador
good morning and good to see you thank
you for having me no and thank you for
coming here to give us on your
first-hand account of what's happening
there you mentioned this I mean 1.2
million Venezuelans are estimated to be
living in Colombia what did you see
firsthand I know you went down there
with the International Rescue Committee
well we saw thousands of people coming
over every day just to buy the most
basic supplies food medicine and many
are staying because they just can't go
home to Venezuela and what we really saw
was that there are millions of children
that are not in school but Colombia
wants to educate them so it was
incredibly heartbreaking but I think it
also gave me great hope I mean you
reminded there is so much natural wealth
in Venezuela even just not only the
people but certainly as I mentioned the
largest oil reserves and you point out
to half of their children are not in
school what are the long-term
implications not only for Venezuela
Colombia the Latin America well this is
the biggest crisis in the refugee crisis
in the world today which I don't think
people read realize until recently and I
think that Colombia is willing to
educate all these children they just
need the resources because the numbers
are so much bigger and all the world
community has a stake in this because if
we invest in the future of these
children now
every humanitarian crisis they'll go
home to built rebuild their own
countries and that's what we really want
we want a stable and prosperous
Venezuela and Colombia school is one of
the few places where you can have a safe
and stable environment and you talk to
kids and say I want to go to school
they're desperate to go to school and
their parents the reason they made the
sacrifice to leave home is to give their
children a better life and to give them
an education and when we intervene or
respond to these humanitarian crisis
only 2 percent of the money goes to
education why is generational don't
think it's I don't say it's a long term
investment it's not a short term crisis
response and so but I think that or it's
the parents responsibility under stand
it because I personally as having worked
in education as a parent mother there's
nothing more important than having
children develop skills develop their
dreams their hope for the lifeline not a
luxury educationally and these kids are
determined to to succeed and so I think
that it's a tiny amount of money and I
think that education has got to be
included with health and shelter as one
of the first things we do yes sir I was
amazed to read with you that you wrote 7
million internally displaced persons in
Colombia the largest in the in the world
where is the United States in in this
conversation it used to be the the
leader of the world in in these kinds of
questions where is the United States
well the contrast you know it you just
can't help but notice it Colombia has
open borders they're welcoming all their
neighbors and they are still recovering
from their own civil war so they're
implementing their own that's why there
are seven million people within Colombia
that have left their own homes so this
is a country that is welcoming everyone
committed to educating them committed to
giving them healthcare so I think that
that's the kind of place that we need to
invest because we can succeed here we
can give these people hope and then they
can return home and rebuild their own
country which is what we all want in
Colombia isn't the only country
neighbouring country that's taking in
these refugees I was in Peru this past
summer they're also taking any one of
these Ecuador Trinidad and Tobago as
well are you in favor of the US current
policy now in supporting wydo and
putting real pressure
maduro hoping that this ends quickly
well I think I'm in favor of working
with our allies and that's something
that seems to be happening which is
unusual for this administration so this
is a fast-moving situation and I really
was focused on kids and education
because that keeps getting left out of
these discussions and you know we end up
talking again about you know all of
these things but it's tremendously
hopeful and the people there our are
just desperate for a new democratic
society where they Caroline always good
to see you you made headlines back in
2008 and you endorsed Barack Obama
anybody catch your eyes so far
I'm so excited there's so many great
people already and more to come are you
saying me knows English at this
particular time I'm not saying that okay
I can't wait okay all right Caroline
fair enough really good to have you here